committee's investigation into fbi
report informants this was recorded by
nbc cameras on december second nineteen
seventy five
people in previous sessions we've
examined the bureau's use of mail
openings
electronic and other means of
surveillance
surreptitious entry
individual and organizational bank
records
income tax returns
and other sources of intelligence
information
it is clear that under proper judicial
scrutiny as mandated by the congress and
the courts
limited invasions of individual privacy
involving any or all of the foregoing
could be properly undertaken
in aid of the bureau's law enforcement
mission
the focus of our inquiry has been
and will continue to be
the use of these and other techniques
without the sanction of judicial
authority
and for purposes often unrelated to law
enforcement
as it has been traditionally defined in
our country
i stress that the mandate of this
committee
is to examine the intelligence gathering
activities of governmental agencies
and does not in any way
encompass an assessment
of the overall fbi law enforcement
effort
we make no attempt
at overall assessment
with respect to those fbi activities
which have come to be known as domestic
intelligence
our inquiry has revealed a further
bifurcation
of the bureau's areas of concern
as previously discussed by the
committee's council in our last session
approximately 20 percent of the bureau's
budget is devoted to intelligence
activities
this is divided between so-called
domestic intelligence
and counter-espionage activities we have
accepted
and we support
the bureau's position that a further
budgetary breakdown detailing the
precise expenditures for each category
might adversely affect the national
interest by revealing the exact amount
of expenditures for counter-espionage
therefore while the nature and extent of
these activities
is less than precise from a budgetary
standpoint
this inquiry nevertheless
represents a critical area
of our investigation
testimony and other evidence received by
the committee to date
indicates that a variety of techniques
not limited to those just cited
were employed against individuals and
organizations
without even color
of legislative or judicial authority
the impact of those abuses on
individuals
and on legitimate political social
religious and philosophical interests
represents a dangerous erosion
of our constitutional guarantees
in council's survey of the the issues
during our last session
we examined a range of activities
extending from information gathering to
disruption of the lives of individuals
and organizations
we witnessed intelligence functions at
their admitted worst
in our review of the so-called counter
intelligence program against dr martin
luther king
today we turn to an in-depth review of
intelligence methods
through an examination of the bureau's
most widely used technique
informants
the concept of informing
is usually distasteful
however the informant technique is a
valid and recognized one in the
intelligence field
often leads to very solid results
at issue
is the bureau's abusive employment of
this technique
and abuse at least partially due to the
absence of clear guidelines concerning
intelligence informants
and the lack of appropriate
constitutional guarantees
the legitimate concern of the fbi
in investigating criminal conduct
and preventing
criminal activities
can never justify allowing informants or
other law enforcement agents to operate
outside the law
without regard for the rights of others
when informant is used to penetrate an
organization
to provide intelligence information
the possible impact of this influence of
his influence
on the activities of that organization
cannot be ignored
surely the infiltration of informants
into groups and organizations
which seek to bring about political
social economic or other changes in our
society
represents
at the very least
a chilling effect on the freedom of
citizens to gather
and to debate
and work for such changes
the fact that an informant in carrying
out his role
may hinder or alter the advancement of
legitimate objectives sought by members
of organizations
is a matter with which we must all be
concerned
furthermore the bureau's use of
informants in large numbers and in
circumstances where the propriety of
having an informant is dubious in the
first place
poses an additional item of concern
as i have already noted the bureau's use
of the informant is part of the fbi's
catalogue of technique for carrying out
its work
our hearing today will focus first
on the roles actually played
by two informants
one who infiltrated the ku klux klan
clan
another who infiltrated vietnam veterans
against the war
the first witnesses today
will be mary jo cook
and gary thomas rowe
mr rowe will be wearing a hood
so that he cannot be physically
identified
he believes that physical identification
would be inimical to his personal safety
he now resides at
a location not to be disclosed under an
alias
which has been given to him by the
government
do you solemnly swear that the testimony
you're about to give before this
committee is the truth the whole truth
and nothing but the truth so help you
god
uh the witnesses are wrecking are
represented by council today would
council please identify themselves for
the record
frank excuse me franklin gerdes for mr
oh
you may be seated
the chair now recognizes
this book is also represented
thank you
the
chair now recognizes the minority
council for the committee committee's
inquiry with examination of
this cook
and ms cook if you will i'd like to
begin by
starting with your first affiliation
with the federal bureau of investigation
if you will
is my understanding that your contact
began
in the summer of 1973.
if you could just briefly for the
committee explain how that contact came
about
yes
excuse me
i was living with a man who would you
pull your mic a little closer
i was living with a man who was working
for the bureau and who had been working
for the bureau for about a couple of
months as an informant
he asked me um
i observed his activities we discussed
his activities and then he subsequently
asked me
if i would consider becoming an
informant
he took me which group was he informing
for he was performing for the fbi and
who was informing about
he was informing on the vietnam veterans
against the war winter soldier
organization
okay he took me to a meeting after we
returned from the meeting we discussed
in more detail how he felt about being
an informant what he did
why he did it
and when i said that i would be open to
talking about being an informant with
the fbi he set up a meeting and then the
fbi came to my house to discuss it with
me
an agent came to visit you for the
purpose of discussing your becoming an
informant
yes what was the nature of that
discussion what were you asked if
anything to do by the fbi
the major understanding that i got from
the meeting was that
vvaw wso was an organization primarily
of veterans who were possible victims of
manipulation they had been through the
vietnam war they had legitimate
readjustment needs
and the bureau was afraid that
they could become violent it could
become manipulated in a cause or social
concern and they wanted me to go in
there participate in the organization
and make sure that the veterans didn't
get
you know quote unquote ripped off so i
was to be you know they used words like
be a voice of reason be a big sister be
a
sort of a guiding force in the
organization and keep things
calm cool and collected that sounded
like a legitimate thing to do so i
agreed to work for the for the fbi
in addition to maintaining reason and
keeping things calm and cool
what other functions any were you
assigned by the fbi
well
this whole scenario that was presented
was called what it was being an
informant
so i was to go to meetings
write up reports or call phone-in
reports on what happened who was there
told
in some way to try to totally identify
the background of every person there
what their what their relationships were
who they were living with they're
sleeping with
um to try to get some some sense of
the local structure and the local
relationships among the people in this
organization
and so i would go to a meeting
identify the people who were present
identify them as individuals and then
identify the substance of the meeting
you identified the attendees by name
yes or by physical description if i
didn't know the name
did you identify
friends of persons who were associated
with the organization yes i did
did you provide information on these
persons places of employment
yes i did
and you said you provided information on
their personal relationships yes i did
how did you come to gain this kind of
information
much of this information would be
initially it would be gathered at a
meeting
people would joke and personal
conversations they would drop
information about themselves as i got to
know them as in as as personal friends
later
then much more information
i had access to much more information
did you report back to the bureau all
information gained
no i did not report back to the bureau
all information
gained in initially when i worked for
the bureau i did i've had little way of
making i was alien to the situation they
said go into this and so
i had no way of really knowing what was
important what wasn't important so in
one sense i was a vacuum cleaner for
information just gathering it
as i became more familiar with the
context within which i was working i was
able to make decisions about what was
important information and what was not
was this on your initiative or were you
given guidance as to what to exclude
this was on my initiative
did you report information on the
political views of these persons
yes i did
miss cook how many people were involved
in this reporting back process how many
people did you report on
well
i figured that there were about 50 core
people in the organization in the local
chapter in buffalo and if you look at it
in concentric circles there's perhaps
250 people in the buffalo community
whose names i identified as being
leadership one way or the other in in
social issues that they were active in
and then perhaps four hundred people
nationally when you take a look at the
national vba wwso and all of the
organizations that i came into contact
with and then when you add to that
the mailing lists that i've turned over
and the names that came into my hands
as being active or interested members of
vba wwso that's perhaps
that may be as many as a thousand names
with respect to the
value of what you had given to the
bureau was there any formal process for
identifying what was important as
opposed to the trivia that may have
resulted from your communications with
them
yes i'm really what i'm asking is what
system if any was communicated to you
regarding the importance of certain
kinds of information
was it determined on the basis of some
guidance by the bureau was it determined
based on the the amount of pay received
for information was there any system
designed to communicate to you what was
important
okay beyond general guidelines
you know
identifying people who were present and
being aware of people with a propensity
for violence there were no guidelines as
to what information was was important or
wasn't
important my financial arrangement with
them was on the basis that i would turn
over all information gathered they would
look it over they would decide what was
of value to them and what wasn't of
value to them pay me accordingly without
necessarily identifying
what they considered essential they
rarely gave me information they really
they didn't define my context and then
asked me to go into it they just said we
want you to go in there we're not going
to tell you anything about it you figure
it out i figured that was fair
and your pay was based on the bureau's
assessment of the value of the
information which you turned on
yes
how long were you involved in the
effort in informing against the veterans
against the war
from june of 73 through november 74
that's approximately a year and a half
did there come a time when you were
either dissatisfied with or raised
questions about your activities as an
informant
yes
when did this occur this occurred
very very much so after july of 1974 i'd
come here to washington and been in
the only large demonstration that i've
ever been in
the bureau had asked me not to go and
advise me not to go i came and i saw
people
people that i'd met in the course of my
activities with blood running down
their heads
i came back from
from washington very upset and i started
talking with the fb about i about all of
the contradictions
that i was starting to see i didn't
understand what my involvement was
anymore
so i just i started saying to them
i don't see the reason for my continuing
it seems to me that you don't understand
what i'm telling you these people don't
need me functioning in their midst and
if you can't give me assurances that the
information that i'm giving you which is
what you seem to strip a context away
from
isn't going to be used against these
people then then i cannot continue
and they couldn't
they tried to give me assurances they
brought someone from washington to talk
to me and he talked in humanist
philosophical terms about why i should
continue and how everything was was was
all fine and good
but i was very dissatisfied with with
those conversations and i insisted on
quitting i gave them a month's notice
and i quit
this person from washington who talked
to you in philosophical terms
do you recall the substance of that
conversation
in this effort to get you to remain as
an informant what kinds of
reasons were advanced
mostly they were trying to assure me
that the fbi
was part of
our our conversations were really
far-ranging we discussed all sorts of
social issues from poverty to the space
program to ecology they tried to assure
me that things were were doing fine the
stress the status quo was really fine i
was involved with a group of people who
had really bad readjustment needs as
veterans who didn't have social programs
that were that were sufficient for them
i was also involved involved in welfare
rights and i was constantly meeting
people who lived with a degree of
poverty
that
that
provoked them and irritated and frust
frustrated them and they turned to
self-help programs so here i have on one
hand a man telling me
that things are fine and that my work
for the bureau is part of
making sure that dissidents who who
somehow
they had no sympathy
with the poverty and the consequences of
that poverty that i was viewing
firsthand in part and and and living
with day to day so that we were really
very much miles apart in our discussions
about
what was fine and what was not fine in
america
and they could not give me the
assurances
that this information would not be used
against people because i i no longer
could trust
that
their interest
in these people that they were just not
sensitive to to what the real needs of
these people were
it it then shortly after this that your
role as an informant was terminated that
you indicated you no longer desire to
work in this capacity
yes
let me just raise one final area of
inquiry with you
in our previous discussion you indicated
that there came a time when you had
become involved in the attica defense
project
representing the vietnam veterans
against the war
and that is a part of such you had been
involved in things like
the jury survey effort
yes
my question is did you communicate to
the bureau
any of your efforts in this regard as
they related to the attica defense
effort
yes i did
i was put in the position i was told not
to
bring to the fbi's attention any
information
that legally they shouldn't have but i'm
not a lawyer and most average citizens
cannot make
decisions about what's legally
significant and what's not legally
significant there are many instances
where i passed information thinking that
i could legitimately pass that
information i now understand that that
information legally the fbi should not
have had that information
and i feel badly about that but i also
know that i was put in the kind of
position where i was required to make
a professional decision and i could not
make a professional decision scott did
the information passed include
correspondence between you and
attica defendants
yes
mr chairman that concludes my
examination witness yes i would from
when to win
from approximately 1959 to 1965.
can you draw the microphone a little
closer to you
from approximately 1959 to 1965
in 1965 did you surface in connection
with a murder case yes i did uh whose
murder and what role did you play in
that case
i was in the automobile the evening the
woman mrs violizio was killed by a group
of clansmen
and this was a situation in connection
with the selma march where
a woman from detroit was killed uh while
she was riding in a car after the march
that is correct
and you surfaced and testified at three
trials which ultimately resulted in a
conviction of the of the um persons who
had committed that murder that is
correct
right i want to go back uh mr rowe to
how you came to that point in what you
did as an informant before performing
that service
had you served in the government prior
to being a clan informant
in the ameri military forces yes sir
you've been a marine yes how old were
you when you became a marine sir i was
joined the marine reserves at 19 at four
and a half years of age
uh and the fbi recruited you to in
infiltrate the clan is that right
that is correct
what kind of information
did you report back to the fbi about the
clan
any and everything that i observed or
heard pertaining to any plans
now did that include information
relating to planned violence or actual
violence yes sir
did it also include information related
to political matters yes sir what's an
example of that
sir an example of that was we had a
former fbi agent running for mayor of
birmingham
i was instructed to attend meetings
observe who was there whether the people
were republicans or democrats if i could
best describe that
and give their names and if they were in
fact active political voters
now in addition to reporting back
political information and information
relating to violence
did you report back information relating
to the social life of the members of the
clan yes right there including the most
intimate details of their social life
and personal life that's what i was
instructed to do you were instructed to
do that by the bureau and you did that
that is correct
did you also
go to meetings of civil rights
organizations and report back what was
being said at those meetings yes i did
and did you report the same information
to the bureau and to the clan about the
civil rights organizations basically the
same information yes sir uh you were a
member of something called the kbi or
the clan bureau of investigation is that
right that is correct so you were in
effect informing on the civil rights
organizations to both the bureau and the
clan that is correct
turning to the subject of violence
uh what instructions if any were you
given at the outset of your employment
by the fd fbi with respect to
participation in violent activity sir i
was instructed under no conditions for
us to participate in any violence
whatsoever now did those instructions
subsequently change yes they did
describe the change would you please
sir i was contacted by
my contact agent he stated to me that he
says quote he said i know there's a lot
of crap going on that you aren't
reporting he said i know it's happening
and i don't understand why you don't see
it i said well it isn't happening in the
open meetings i can tell you that
i give you every night a written report
of my meeting i said there's absolutely
nothing pertaining to the violence
discussed in these open meetings however
i see a group that stay after the
meeting is over i see a certain group
remain
and they don't come out when we do the
agent stated that i should try to get
closer to members of this certain group
find out who they were and try to get
closer to them when did you do that yes
i did and then did you begin to
participate yourself in the violent acts
yes i did uh and did you tell the fbi
that you were participating in violent
acts before i participated in the access
i did what were some of the acts that
you participated in
the violent acts sir the major one was
the birmingham freedom right now i'm
going to come to that in a moment did
you also participate in acts where you
beat people with chains at
a certain county fair
yes sir there was a county fair in
western alabama
the fbi i personally gave the fbi
several days notice
a a good week
noticed that this was going to occur
my instructions were well to hang in
uh go and see what happens it's working
work your way in and did the fbi ever
tell you that
when you went to these violent
occasions you should stand back and not
participate or did they say you're on
your own and do whatever you think is
necessary sir they stated to me quote he
says we have to by law
to instruct you that you're not to
participate in any violence however we
know you've got to do this we know it's
something that you've got to do and we
understand so we need the information
that's the important thing get the
information and to get the information
was it necessary in your judgment to
participate in the violent acts yourself
some of the information i think yes and
some i would say no sir right in
connection with the freedom writers
incident that you mentioned
uh did you inform the fbi about planned
violence prior to that incident sir i
gave them
fbi information pertaining to the
freedom riders assault approximately
three weeks before it occurred
and what did you tell them i stated to
them that i had been contacted by a
birmingham city detective who in turn
wanted me to meet with a
high-ranking officer of the birmingham
police department to set a reception for
the freedom riders you mean the
birmingham policeman
set up the beating of the freedom riders
and you told the fbi that that's correct
and then were they beaten they were
beating very badly yes and did the
birmingham police give you the time that
they promised to give you to perform the
beat yes sir we were promised 15 minutes
with absolutely no intervention from any
police officer whatsoever
the
information was passed on to the bureau
a
we had our 15 minutes approximately 15
minutes after the freedom riders
were attacked a police officer ran over
to me and
stated goddammit god damn it get out of
here get him out of here your 15 minutes
are up we're sending the crew in
all right were any arrests made
absolutely none sir as a matter of fact
i quit very shortly after working for
the bureau because of this incident i
felt that my exact phrase was why wasn't
something done there were a thousand men
at least on mother's day of the morning
of the freedom riders just roaming up
down right in front of city hall we had
baseball bats we had clubs we had chains
we had pistols sticking in our belts it
was just unbelievable but that's the
problem of the birmingham police
department what about the fbi did you
ever discuss with them why they
certainly i was told by the fbi quote he
said well who the hell were we going to
report it to he said the police
department was involved in it the police
department helped set it up with you
he said we are an investigating agency
not an enforcement agency all we do is
gather information that was my answer
now approx sometime after that were you
told that the fbi had declared war on
the klan and given the name of something
called cointelpro
that is correct
and what were you told to do under the
cointelpro program sir under the
cointelpro program i had
been instructed to disrupt this credit
or disorganize the clan organization the
best of my ability and what things did
you do in that connection i was
instructed to
give information if i find out who was
sleeping with who if somebody was
sleeping with another klansman's wives
or was going with someone i was to try
to pass the word around to the different
people so that cost ascension in their
homes and try to break up their homes i
was also instructed to attend church
services in the regular church service
to see if they were any political
activities going on or mentioned in
church services as opposed to the clan
meetings
many clan meetings were held in churches
were you also instructed personally
yourself to attempt to break up
marriages by
sleeping with wives of members of the
camp clan yes i was my instructions were
to try to sleep with as many wives as i
could that was probably the best
information we could get
all right and that's all i have
uh mr chairman except then thereafter
you did
solve as we started the lyoto murder
by providing information to the fbi that
led to the solution of that crime
yes i did pass the information
committee
will stand in recess for three minutes
while we bring forth the other witnesses
uh
[Music]
now your question is what criteria what
criteria do you use in the selection of
informants well the criteria vary with
the needs
in our
cases relating to extremist matters
surely in order to get an informant who
can meld into a group which is invade
engaged in a criminal type activities
you're going to have a different set of
criteria
if you're talking about our internal
security matters i think we set rather
high standards we do require
that a preliminary
inquiry be conducted which would consist
principally of
checks of
our headquarters indices our field
office indices
checks with other informants who are
operating in the same area and with
various established sources such as
local police department
following this if it would appear that
the person is the type who has
credibility can be defended upon to be
reliable
we would interview the individual
in order to make an a determination as
to whether or not he would be willing
to assist the fbi in discharging its
responsibilities in that field
following that assuming that the answer
was positive
we would conduct a rather in-depth
investigation
for the purpose
of further attempting to establish
credibility and reliability
how does the
bureau distinguish
between the use of informants for
law enforcement
as opposed to intelligence collection
is the guidance any different or is it
the same of what
well mr addy it was passed on to those
who had the responsibility to do
something about it it was not always
acted upon as he indicated
and none of these cases then there was
adequate evidence of conspiracy to give
you jurisdiction to act the departmental
rules at that time
and still do require
departmental approval where you have a
conspiracy
under 241
it takes two or more persons
acting together you can have a mob scene
and you can have blacks and whites
belting each other but unless you can
show that those that initiated the
action acted in concert in a conspiracy
you have no violation
congress recognized this and it wasn't
until 1968
that they came along and added section
245 to the civil rights statute which
added
punitive measures against an individual
there didn't have to be a conspiracy
but this was a problem that the whole
country was grappling with the president
of the united states attorney general's
uh
we were in a situation where we had rank
uh lawlessness taking place that
as you know from the memorandum we sent
you that we sent to the attorney general
the
accomplishments we were able to obtain
in preventing violence and in
neutralizing the klan and that was one
of the reasons
what was the bureau's purpose in
and continuing or urging continued
informant surveillance
of the vietnam veterans against the war
was there a legitimate law enforcement
purpose or was the intent to alter
political expression
we had information on the vietnam
veterans against the war
it indicated that
there were subversive groups involved
they were going to north vietnam
meeting with the communist forces they
were going to paris attending meetings
paid for and sponsored by the communist
party the international communist party
we feel that
we had a very valid basis to
direct our attention to the vvaw
it started out of course with gus hall
in 1967
uh who was head of the communist party
usa with comments he made what it
finally boiled down to is a situation
where it split off
into the revolutionary union which was a
maoist group
and
the hard-line communist group and at
that point factionalism developed in
many of the chapters and we closed those
chapters because there was no longer any
intent to follow the national
organization
but we had a valid basis for
investigating it and we investigated
chapters to determine if there was
affiliation and subservience to the
national office mr one all was and not
intervening in
in the rose situation when violence was
known well senator schweiker mr adams
did address himself to that if you have
no objections i'll ask that
uh the problem we had at the time
was that the f and it's the the problem
today we're an investigative agency we
do not have police powers even like the
united states marshals do the marshall
since
about 1795 i guess or some period like
that have
authorities that almost border on what a
sheriff has
we're the investigative agency of the
department of justice and during these
times the department of justice
had us maintain the role of an
investigative agency we were to report
on activities
we furnished the information to the
local police who had an obligation to
act we furnished it to the department of
justice
in those areas where the local police
did not act it resulted finally
in the attorney general sending 500
united states marshals down to guarantee
the safety of people who were trying to
march in protest of their civil rights
this was an extraordinary measure
because it came at a time of
civil rights versus program since it's
obvious to me that a lot of informers
are going to have pre-knowledge of
violence of using u.s marshals on some
kind of a of a long-range basis to
prevent violence
we have them in boston in connection
with the busing incident we're
investigating the violations
uh under the civil rights act but the
marshals are in boston they're in
louisville i believe at the same time
and this is the approach that the
federal government finally recognized uh
was the solution to the problem where
you had to have
added federal import but instead of
waiting until it gets to to a boston
state which is obviously pretty advanced
uh confrontation uh
shouldn't we have somewhere a
coordinated program that when uh when
you go up the ladder of command the fbi
that on on a uh immediate and fairly uh
uh
contemporary basis that kind of help can
be sought instantly as opposed to
waiting until it gets to a boston i
realize departure from the past i'm not
saying it isn't but
it seems to me we need a better remedy
than we have well fortunately we're at a
time where conditions have subsided in
the country
uh even from the 60s and the 70s and
periods
are 50s and 60s
we report to the department of justice
on potential
trouble spots around the country
uh as we learn of them so that the
department will be aware of them the
planning for boston for instance took
place a year in advance
with state officials
city officials the department of justice
and the fbi our approach our only
approach was through informants
and through the use of informants we
solved these cases
the ones that were solved there were
some of the bombing cases we never
solved they're extremely difficult
but
these informants
as we told the attorney general and as
we told the president that we had moved
informants like mr rowe up to the top
leadership he was the bodyguard to the
head man
he was in a position where he could
forewarn us of violence could help us on
cases that had transpired and yet we
knew and could see
that this could continue forever unless
we can create enough disruption that
these members will realize that if i go
out and murder three civil rights
workers even though the sheriff
and other law enforcement officers are
in on it
if that were the case and some of them
it was the case that
i will be caught
and that's what we did and that's why
violence stopped was because the clan
was insecure and just like you say
20 percent they thought 50
of their members ultimately were clan
members and they didn't dare engage in
these acts of violence because they knew
they couldn't control the conspiracy any
longer
so um
i'm sorry i have my time here i just
have one quick question is it correct
that in 1971
we were using around 6 500 informers for
black ghetto
uh
situation i'm not sure if that's the
year we did have one year where we had a
number
like that which would have probably been
around 6 000 and that was the time of
the when the cities were being burned
detroit washington areas like this we
were given a mandate to know
what the situation is where is violence
going to break out
next they weren't informants like uh a
an individual that's penetrating an
organization they were listening post
in the community that would help tell us
that we have a group here that's getting
ready to start another firefight or
something
thank you thank you mr chairman um
there are
three more senators from remaining for
questioning if we can go if you can try
to get everything in in your first round
it may be the best professional
organization of its kind in the world
but when the fbi acts in the field of
political ideas
it's
bundled its job
it's interfered with civil liberties
and finally in the last month or two
through its public disclosure is heaped
to shame upon itself
and really led toward
an undermining of crucial public
confidence in an essential law
enforcement agency of this country
in a real sense history has repeated
itself
because it was precisely that problem
that led to the creation of the fbi in
1924
in world war one the bureau of
investigation strayed from its law
enforcement functions
it seems to be the
the basis of this strategy that people
can't protect themselves from dangerous
ideas
that they somehow you need to use the
tools of law enforcement to protect
people from
subversive or dangerous ideas
which i find strange and quite violent
quite
profoundly at odds with the philosophy
of american government
i started politics
years ago
and the first thing we had
we've got to control this restrain it
define it
so that precisely what's expected of the
fbi is known by you
by the public
and that you can justify your actions
when
when we ask you
i agree with that senator and i would
like to point out that when the
attorney general made his statement uh
mr hoover subscribed to it
we followed that policy for about 10
years until the president of the united
states said we should investigate the
nazi party i for one feel that we should
investigate the nazi party i feel that
uh our investigation of the nazi party
resulted in the fact that in world war
ii is contrasted to world war one there
wasn't one
single incident of foreign directed
sabotage which took place in the united
states and under the criminal law well
you would have investigated
these issues of sabotage isn't sabotage
your crime sabotage is a crime but yeah
did you investigate it then after it
happened see every time you get
challenged on on getting involved in
political ideas you defend yourself on
the basis of crimes that you've been
investigating it's very interesting in
my opinion you've got to stand here
if you're going to continue what you're
now doing and as i understand it you
still insist you did the right thing
with the vietnam veterans against the
war and investigating the council of
churches now this could still go on
this can still go on under your
interpretation of your present powers
which you try to justify on the grounds
of your law enforcement activities in
terms of criminal matters
the law does not say we have to wait
until we have been
murdered before we can absolutely
but that's the field of law again
it's the field of law but trying to
defend when you have sabotage
touch the law you can do that you guys
that's right but you can't how do you
find out which of the 20 000 boon
members might have been a saboteur you
don't have probable cause to investigate
anyone but you direct an intelligence
type investigation against the german
american boon that's correct the same
thing we did after congress said and
could you get a warrant for that why do
you object to going to a court and
asking for authority because you don't
have probable cause to go against an
individual
and the law doesn't provide for probable
cause to investigate an organization
uh there were
activities which did take place like at
one time they were going to outlaw the
communist party uh which didn't come
about we could
what i don't understand is why it
wouldn't be better for the fbi
for us to define authority that you
could use in the kind of bond situation
where
under court authority you could
investigate where there's probable cause
or reasonable cause to suspect
sabotaging the rest wouldn't that make a
lot more sense than just
making these decisions on your own we
have expressed complete concurrence in
that we feel that we're going to get
beat to death for the next 100 years the
damned if you do and damned if you don't
right if we don't have a delineation of
our responsibility in this area
the hearings you've just been watching
took place inside this room on december
2nd 1975